what's the biggest hindrance to a
creative person and then on the positive
side it's a creative person's biggest
asset same thing self-confidence so
that's a short answer for ya lots of
beautiful answers right does someone get
that if a it's not naturally and we know
that it's not instilled in many of us
many of us are deeply insecure
many of us are naturally introverts like
myself and it's really difficult to I
had to train myself to get up and talk
in front of a room of people and find my
voice and be able to have the words
still come out of my mouth and anything
that is that is halfway decent I think
the way you do it I'll just tell you for
me I think you acted I think you it's
like a suit of clothes that you put on
and you grow accustomed to wearing the
suit of clothes and eventually you said
well really is my shirt I can really
wear the clothes I think it's some level
that insecurity never goes away you know
probably I certainly know people who are
highly respected really gifted famous
highly paid creative people or deeply
deeply insecure so that may you know
there's some level at which that never
did banishes but being able to find the
confidence to put yourself out there and
put your work out there to believe in
yourself and to persist persist persist
in it is something that I think people
just do by doing kind of have to do it
by doing it's really like any other
craft you you can read about making
movies but you don't learn how to make a
movie - you pick up a camera and you
shoot things and then you get today a
room and discover oh I didn't shoot the
right things and you have to go back the
next day and you discover all those
things you could do it by doing it
you